I want to talk about your character in
my Lois Brooklyn because it's his
fascinating character he's sort of an
up-and-coming detective works you know
who's an associate an associate and you
know sort of in the trade but he's
burdened with he has Tourette's yes
syndrome I don't even think they it
takes place in the 50s one they don't
even have a name for it or they don't
really he doesn't know they call him
people calling freak show because they
literally don't know what his problem is
the this rise condition for people who
don't aren't familiar with Tourette's
you know he has a lot of physical
twitches and compulsions and a lot of
vocal tics and the tendency to yell yell
out things that he can't you know and
it's a flying line because I found
myself at times you would play it in
this way that's very real and also there
are things you do that there there are
moments that are really funny and you
realize like oh you're walking this
really thin line but you're doing it
really well where you're you're enjoying
this performance and also it's this
which is I look I think you know III
think there's a great tradition of
underdog heroes like you know like
Forrest Gump and Rain Man and yep yep
this guy's a little tougher I mean this
guy's a Street tough Brooklyn orphan who
works for Bruce Willis who Bruce is the
real the real Private Eye and he
recognizes the talent in this guy
underneath his chaotic condition and and
but but I think you know what's what's
always most interesting is is yes you
want to get an accurate representation
the condition and and and there is humor
in it there is he recognizes that
there's humor among him and his friends
other times it's it's more shocking and
other times it's really painful they're
there right there's moments of it
there's real suffering we have a moment
here I think this is a clip we're going
to show where you're you're doing the
classic I think this is you this plastic
detective sort of Norfolk yeah let's
just say let's just say in the in the
moment where Bogart would be very smooth
with the blonde the bar this Lionel has
a difficulty he has a hard time with
he has to repeat them until they sound
right yeah and and at the exact moment
you would want to be like Bogart or
Nicholson very cool it goes very off the
rails
let's take of this clip from motherless
Brooklyn scene that guy veneers yeah
nice face if nice yourself you gotta
light cheese sorry
geez forget I asked he wants to impress
it's not gonna happen yeah yeah at this
amazing job on this project I just I
can't imagine wearing that many hats on
a film must be where you're in it you're
directing it you've written it you know
who you can you [ __ ] to this script is
[ __ ] oh yeah that's me you know I on the
other hand I have very efficient
conversations with myself good
you know I'm if I'm being a whiny actor
and I want another take I you know I can
shut myself down very quickly very
nicely dumb but it sorta you know I
think that in the end he he has to kind
of come out of his shell and and finds
that the ways that his condition are a
gift and I think I think there are we
probably all know people with Tourette's
that we don't even know that's what they
have because some of them have the and
they make a career out of it like Puss I
often identify with me you know and II
will back me up on this I'm constantly
babbling I will have a twitchy energy I
think yeah Andy thanks a lot
does he say he said over here like a
mute as you like it's a technique I've
learned over over long year to brag no
but I just think I think think about it
like like the impulse to say the most
inappropriate thing at exactly with no
inhibition yeah there's money in that
I'm tired so for some people instead of
fliction and for some it's a career
thank you I think we learned a lot here